let's go to your story so um
in your book deep undercover my secret
life entangled the allegiances as a kgb
spy in america and in the really really
excellent podcast series that i've been
listening to it's people should
definitely listen to it's called the
agent
you document your time as a kgb spy
before during and after
can you tell the story when you first
were contacted by the kgb those
how you were
in invited the offer to join was made
well
it was a big surprise and i i never
thought of myself as uh as a potential
agent you know i i was going to be a
tenured professor
and join the ruling elite because in
in in europe tenured professors are few
it's not like in the united states you
know anybody who teaches at colleges as
a as a title of professor easy now
it's true yes that's not a criticism
so we should also clarify that to any
professor or not
it is a very prestigious position
throughout history of europe
and i would say especially communist
i don't actually know the full
landscape of the respect but at least in
the soviet union where i grew up it's a
prestigious position absolutely was uh
and the the town of yena had about a
hundred thousand people live there and
um
i would it's a wild guess but maybe 30
tenured professors and they were part of
the ruling elite i was
trying to do it as much as i can to live
the good life right you know
you know have access to things that uh
that are nice
yeah but i think
the powerful thing about
being a professor in that context of
east germany
is the prestige and the feeling of
superiority
you know i i was full of myself you know
when when when you are the best of the
best and i and i in my third year i
received a scholarship
uh the carl marx scholarship uh that was
limited to 100 concurrent recipients in
the country
so my god no i i was full of myself i i
believed in myself hook hook line and
sinker and and and i was also
uh
uh this
i got a lot of
accolades from teachers and
fellow students they were feeding the
ego the old
i mean yeah you have to believe in
yourself uh often when you're young to
truly right right to excel and and you
sure liked it
but you know as a balance you need a
mentor somebody who
puts things in perspective and i didn't
have one
my father wasn't non-entity and nobody
else they they all looked up to me
yeah i was an up-and-coming guy right so
there's no father figure that put you in
your place not at all and and i give you
one extreme example it was down the road
when i
fathered a child out of wedlock
um
um that was in my fifth year i believe
the the communist party in east germany
was uh very moralistic if you did that
they would have a talk with you and
give you whatever severe reprimand
nobody even mentioned a word about this
so yeah so this is this is how this ego
gets gets nurtured but anyway getting
back to how the kgb uh
came in contact so they most likely
got uh
knowledge of me by you know looking at
the stasi
uh records
what's stasi oh that was east german
secret police stat zika height uh
security uh for the state
there's that word security again
[Laughter]
and that they pretty much kept the
record uh on on everybody in the country
and um
so when you when you look through this
in and and this is what the kgb was
looking for they were looking for
candidates
particularly for this kind of job that
they had in mind for me for candidates
uh
who were not you know in their mid 20s
uh who were not fully developed yet but
mature enough
to to get there
uh
and and and still young enough right
because because at that level of
maturity you can test whether they can
handle this kind of yes
absolutely right so and uh um one day i
got a knock on my door and my dorm room
door was on a saturday
um
and
they knew
that
i was by myself how did they know it
uh we had a
i pieced this together
and we had an
exchange student from the soviet union
and he was next door
uh and to me and he
you know he
he befriended me so he he got to know me
a little bit
and and
the pattern was that my roommate would
always go home for the weekend
and of course they also knew which door
to knock on even though there were no
name plates right so
somebody knocks
and
i knew it was a stranger because if it
had been a student
the the pattern was that we would knock
on the door and then go in
we wouldn't wait for somebody to let us
in
so i didn't i waited for 10 seconds and
i
then he didn't come in i knew that was a
stranger i said come on in
and then came a person uh who spoke
fluent german so that was not a kgb guy
there was a collaborator
uh when and so he started making a bunch
of small talk he introduced himself as
the uh
as a representative of cult size yana
which was the
optics uh um
um
company that made that was made really
really good optical instruments was one
of the best in the world
so it's like though
you know
the the super prestigious company in
that place right and he said you know
that he was a representative of that
company
and he
would just want to find out if what my
plans were after graduating from college
and at that point i knew he wasn't from
california
because in those days there was no
recruitment
you when when you were done
uh
if you were in the top 10 of the
graduates
you
would most likely pick to stay and get a
doctorate right
and the rest of them were assigned you
know where you had no choice
so that guy was
an idiot
he he he didn't know the basics
about you interviewed him a little bit
to understand like oh sure you know i
you know i started like feel out is this
guy full of [ __ ]
because yeah he's a stranger showing up
to your dorm room and i knew that
at that point i knew he was stasi which
was wrong but it doesn't matter because
it was german and i had no idea that the
kgb would be involved so i'm sorry to
pause briefly
did you have a sense
did people know that there's a stasi
type of organization
that there is
a large number of people doing this kind
of work in east germany
in order for you to make that guess
yeah we we we knew that the stasi
existed uh we we even had our uh james
bond you know we had a series
uh called the invisible visor where and
a stasi employee in east german would go
into west germany and hunt down nazis
yes so yes the stasi was was known to be
there and admired in part
or feared or both i i thought they were
necessary and
i admired them uh james bond the read
yes the reason
i did so because i had no information to
the contrary
i never knew
anybody
personally or even you know
somewhat removed who was uh
uh
followed by the stasi uh
was uh
you know put in jail
uh i had no clue i had no clue that they
did a lot of damage and that they were
like doing a lot of surveillance of of
the east german population the same way
the kgb did for for the soviet union so
for me to
be talking to somebody from the stasi it
was it
it raised my interest i was curious what
comes next because i sort of knew
something interesting would be coming at
me
and i
i had no i had no other thoughts about
that at that point so when when he was
finally when he uh
he went and he went for the kill by uh
reversing himself he said you know i got
to tell you that i really i really am
not from cal state you know i'm from the
government okay thank you for pointing
that out and then
he asked this question he says can you
imagine to one day work for the
government
and so i
gave a pretty clever answer i said yes
but not as a chemist
so
we i answered the question that he
didn't ask
i helped him out
so we made an arrangement to me meat for
uh
lunch which in germany is the main meal
at the number one restaurant in indiana
you know i still remember what i ate uh
what was that rum steak with uh
with butter on top
and french fries was my favorite
anyway so
when i get to the restaurant uh
i saw this fellow sitting in the back
there at the table and uh there was
another person at the table so i was a
little bit hesitant because in those
days
uh it was not unusual for for perfect
strangers to share a table because there
wasn't wound enough
tables and chairs and so forth so i
didn't know if i could approach him but
he he got up and came to me and he took
me to the table and he said
i want to introduce uh
uh herman we work with our
soviet comrades
aha kgb
and then he he disappeared he says i got
something else to do i never knew his
name
i
he just handed me over to the kgb
what was the relationship between the
kgb and stasis as uh
collaborators close collaborators or
just distant associates uh they were
pretty close collaborators as i told you
that uh you know they they they bought
uh forged documents that the germans
made because the germans were better at
forgery
uh they also exchanged information but
they didn't trust each other 100 and and
and i and i tell you why i know that
so they recruited me to send me to west
germany
as i already said east germany had a
thousand agents over there why would
they have to want to have their own
yeah
yeah okay this is a fascinating internal
and external dynamic of distrust yeah
okay so there you are
uh welcomed by the kgb when did the
offer the invite come well that took a
while so herman and i uh had an
unofficial relationship for about a year
and a half
i would meet him uh
maybe once a week once every two weeks
initially in his car but then uh
he uh
he um he took me to a
conspirational flat this was a an
apartment that was
uh occupied by
a a party member a lady single lady
when we came in she would leave she left
us tea and cookies and then we could
freely talk he also
at that time gave me some
west german literature magazines to read
which was of course forbidden
so already i'm starting to feel somewhat
special
and as we were talking about
what they had in mind for me in general
i knew that i was going to be even more
special because
i would be above the law
i would i would operate outside the law
of the countries i would go to as well
as
uh east germany because you know that
the magazines and uh and eventually when
i joined up
they told me i had better watch west
german television which was also
not explicitly prohibited but it was uh
uh
something that could get you in trouble
so on many levels you're super special
you're the jazz bond yes yes so what was
that
recruitment testing process like
testing whether you
are you have what it takes to be a kgb
agent first of all um
we had very in-depth talks uh me on
herman and i
uh about life
and i
i was
i still am
very honest and
sharing my feelings uh philosophical or
personal personal personally i even i
even told him that i was shy around the
girls
uh
he was giving you relationship advice or
what how old was he so what was the
dynamic can you tell me was it a father
son no older brother older brother
brother yeah he was uh maybe in his uh
early to mid 30s and i was maybe 10
years younger and what languages did he
speak oh you speak german he spoke
german pretty well oh but he's
originally from ohio yeah with a russian
accent
so i got in trouble one time with him
when when i asked him is your real name
german
he didn't like that he didn't like it
what was he good with girls was was no
no he just you know
i remember what he told me he says you
know you gotta understand one thing
they're looking for guys too
that's that's all you know oh uh girls
are looking good
yeah
it's a competitive game yeah yeah don't
don't don't worry about it you know
don't be so shy so that little flame of
love that we talked about yeah in all
the shapes that it takes in our life
did he talk to you about that that that
could be taken advantage of that that
could be used or was it implied
yeah but not in
it was not very focused not in great
detail so let's uh so we talked about
personal stuff and
you know like dislikes he gave me tasks
for instance uh when
my friend and i hitchhiked from from
east germany all the way down to
bulgaria he told me to write a report
about it what i saw so
fundamentally he wanted to see how well
i can
i can write
and how well i can report how well i
observe
he also asked me to write some profiles
about fellow students i don't believe
that was for them to give him to the
stasi it was just like
how well do i characterize people what's
that that's important when you're
talking about
when i was in the u.s
active in the us i operated as a spotter
so i did exactly that i wrote profiles
about people
uh he also gave me some tasks to do that
were
rather unpleasant
um
what um
he would give me an address and the name
of uh uh of uh
the people who lived at the address
and he told me to
go there
ring the doorbell and find out something
about a relative who lived in west
germany
uh that is undercover exploration right
so you go you you make up a story and
somehow
win the confidence of your target
to tell you something that you want to
know
was that did that come naturally to you
no no i hated it the charisma involved
which part did you hate drisma i think i
didn't know that i had it
it took you some time to discuss because
you know i was i always was and i still
am to some degree a bit shy
uh i lost a lot of the shyness uh after
moving to the south because uh here in
the united states because
uh you don't have to be shy you know
you can
let your love shine that's exactly right
so but anyway i i hated doing that but i
i did it well i still remember so i in
those days i had a i had a beard
and uh i i rang the bell and tall
handsome fella yeah and uh and i i
looked the part i said i'm i'm a
sociology student
and i'm i'm doing a survey and i asked a
whole bunch of questions can would you
like to answer the questions
no problem
and then i directed the conversation to
the lady's private life and
and she actually gave me information she
volunteered information
that i wanted to know beautiful i did
well and the other one uh that i didn't
like but i also did well with when uh
when herman
drove me around the city and showed me a
building and he said find out
what organization is in there what they
do
uh maybe get to know some people and i
did that pretty well also
you know
you have to be inventive you know too
to come up with a cover story and and
i've always been quite uh
uh inventive uh you know i'm a
storyteller uh and uh at heart and that
i didn't know it then but that you know
but there was still something unpleasant
about it yes yes which part was
the shyness and then you know
you know i wasn't very comfortable lying
i became comfortable down the road but
you know i i was
brutally honest
and i never
never hit anything of me
uh
but you know over time
you lose that
that
uncomfortable feeling
and you rationalize that you got to do
it
there's only one way right and you're
serving a good cause so you were talking
to herman for a year and a half a year
and a half and then how did that
progress yes so he said he finally i
guess he sent a report to headquarters
in berlin
and then he sent me uh on a three-week
quote-unquote practice trip to berlin
this was the first time when i had an
and like
conspiracy conspiratorial meeting where
i would i had an address at the time and
a code phrase and i met
another agent
his name was boris
these names me were meaningless they
were all like cover names right so what
was the code and the meaning what was
then what can you give a little more
than that i don't remember no not the
code but like what do you mean by code
i tell you my the the code we used when
i when i met while i was active uh
i would approach the other person who i
thought maybe the the person i want to
meet we both had
uh some something to
with us or on us to make us more likely
to be the right person
so and i would uh i would ask him the
following questions
excuse me or
i'm looking for susan green
and he and he would answer yes you must
be david
stupid if if i
if i ask a stranger they would look at
me
how could i help you so yeah no one's
the wrong guy yeah it's just a low
probability that that the right thing
would be so it's absolutely nice
and it seems like a safe statement yes
if it's not the right person exactly
right you'll just come off you absurd or
crazy or whatever you you would have you
would have made a good secret agent you
you know i know i'm not this is this is
we'll discuss this
uh
i'm dressed like one actually yeah where
there's any dress code
no just fit in
fit in no matter what and then be
creative yeah figure out ways to ride
so anyways he give me some tasks and we
and he
since i i had rented a room in a house
he gave me uh
western literature to read
and we spent time together
um
and
there was
a practice run
to west germany actually there were
two and that was very important in
hindsight i figured that out
uh so
i traveled to west germany
uh you know not to west berlin with an
east german passport that was stamped
that that individual was allowed to go
to the west
and there was a
a part of the uh border that was
only
guarded by soviet troops
and that's when they smuggled me into
west germany i got on the subway uh and
and then uh
uh appeared in in west berlin no no no
americans no birds no french knew that
that i had entered uh forged documents
or not no no no no this was a
an east german passport it was real okay
okay so uh and uh the first trip
all they wanted me to do is just walk
around
you know smell the air
uh
you know have a beer or whatever and and
eat a sausage and then come back
the second trip i had a task
very similar to the one that i had back
in yena
to ring the doorbell someplace and uh
talk to some people and that worked very
well as also
i i should mention that you talk about
that you know eat a sausage drink some
beer i suppose that's a good test too
to see how you behave under western
like when first introduced to the
western college like uh this is why i
might not make a good
agent
is when i first
came to the united states and
supermarket
oh like bananas as many bananas as i
want to eat
that i think i would that i think that
would break me
it's just just it's a shock to be uh to
have access to western culture you're
getting
very close to the reason they actually
made me do this these two practice trips
the
when i first emerged on west berlin
territory
i felt highly uncomfortable
that was at the enemy right yeah and i
saw the cops everywhere and even those
those cops had like
light blue uniforms nothing they weren't
standouts so i was wondering you know if
they knew that you know i had like kgb
yeah on my forehead you were paranoid
that they would know they would see i
was scared but i i overcame that so
that's can we just linger on that
because
i suppose that's a natural
like if i give anybody on the street the
mission to do the mission you had to do
is they would be paranoid that's the
natural human
feeling is am i being watched do they
know
um like if you try to steal something
from a store
there's going to be a feeling like
are they watching me are the cameras
watching are they people watching me
they all know that kind of stuff so you
have to overco you have to be somehow
rugged and robust to that kind of
feeling and overcome it yes exactly so
and and uh
something very interesting happened uh
while i was being trained in berlin i
met a classmate of mine from high school
and he confided to me that he was
recruited by the stasi
to become inspire go as a spy to west
germany
and he also had this practice trip
and he peed in his pants he went back
and told him i can't do that just from
the terror the the yes that paranoia now
this guy's career was
over he hadn't he had an uh he had an
engineering degree
he was a pretty smart guy
he he was just for the rest of his life
and he's still alive i believe floating
around and you know
trading in uh
model railroads and stuff like that you
mean do you think that experience broke
them
or they wouldn't let him back in oh i
see they
yeah so this it's a test that if you
fail you pay the price i have no idea
that that uh
you know
uh something bad would happen if i
failed that test but i didn't yeah
i didn't fail so
and this led then to the offer all right
and after and you know boris was happy
with me and he told his boss who was
most likely the
the head of the kgb in in in east berlin
and i had an appointment to meet in east
germany
yes in east germany yeah all of east
germany yes that's right
an appointment to meet with him
and as we walk into the room uh
there was this huge desk and the little
guy sitting behind it
very very
uh
just like little and not unimpressive
nice
a lot of paraphernalia like you know
at a bust of uh jazinski on on on this
desk and and some some
some paintings uh lennon and so forth
but when the guy opened his mouth
he was like whoa
uh huge uh psychological energy
he spoke only russian
now and initially he would you know
start about with five minutes worth of
propaganda why we're doing what we're
doing i didn't need that
i understood most of it uh but what i
when when i didn't understand i'd ask
boris to translate and then
then he sprung it on me and i was not
prepared
he said so what are you in or not
i was no i'm gonna i hadn't made up my
mind
i wasn't expecting that would come and
so um
i said to him
i'm not really trained you know there's
a lot of things i need to learn and i
came up with a couple of really stupid
things one not so stupid but the other
one was i don't know why i said that i
said for instance i need to learn how to
drive a car and to type with a
typewriter
and he he was he got really annoyed and
he said don't worry about it we'll train
you
yeah but
i gotta tell you we need people who are
decisive so i you got until tomorrow
noon to give boris your decision
that made for a sleepless night so what
was going through your mind well i had
uh
this was almost 50 50. uh i i knew i was
gonna have a huge
career a good career i would i was on my
way
because you know this i was already
employed by the university as an
assistant professor so that career would
be uh to become a professor become a
tenured professor be a world class yes
uh jena had become my hometown
i really loved the place it was my
oyster
and then and my family
was my basketball team
i was you you you loved playing
basketball
you mean yeah so this is home is this
home this is where your love is this is
home
did you understand that the choice
involved leaving yes home behind yes
and and uh the one thing i didn't have
the two things i didn't have an
emotional relationship with my mother
and i didn't have a steady girlfriend at
the time
i think freud would have a lot to say
about that but yeah go ahead but the
connection between those two but yes
yeah i'm sure by the way my my my friend
gunther the one who worked for the stasi
was also the stars he tried to recruit
him as an agent but he
had a love relationship at the time and
uh
he said politely no i i won't i can't
so you didn't have that's the one thing
that really could uh would have helped
me would have held you to this place is
love so you got the career on the one
hand my basketball team the town that i
would be part of the ruling elite of
and then we had this great adventure and
the ability to uh contribute
to
the victory the worldwide victory of
communism and and stick it to the nazis
and of course the feeling that you're
really special yeah james bond yeah
what's
[Laughter]
the the question do i want to be a
ten-year professor or james bond yes and
and that's as funny as that sounds that
was probably a difficult decision it was
a difficult decision but fundamentally
it wasn't it and it wasn't my uh zeal
uh
to to help the revolution it was
my
uh
my uh what they called
what they started was looking for the
kgb was looking for in in a character
that they would send over a
well-controlled inclination to adventure
okay
[Laughter]
yeah yeah james bond what do you say
and the love of women yeah
it was
yes uh but i i gotta put this in right
here because i i'm telling people i have
two things in common with james bond
these are my initials jb and and i got
the girl too
three times
[Laughter]
yeah i mean that that's and that's
adventure yeah and and uh
and and the ability to travel to the
west because the west was closed off to
us we could go to foreign countries but
they all had to be communist countries
you know i wanted to see paris because i
i had
fallen in love with the
onori balzac who
phenomenal set of novels that i just ate
up
and so i when i eventually did go to
paris i knew all the places already
because he described them all but anyway
so that one it was a
it was 5149
but eventually it and you know when you
when you do the side-by-side um
intellectual comparison
that doesn't work
it becomes a tie and then you know you
just go with your guard and i said hey
i'm in so now that you successfully
passed the test
and you were sitting with this
unimpressive man and had the invite
and had to sleep on it
and have made the decision to join yeah
what was next
i was just told you know that i was
being recruited by the state department
of east germany i was going to
become a diplomat
i must have had some paper but i forgot
because
you just by saying so then that would
that wouldn't have worked there's some
kind of document that says yeah yeah and
that was the only entanglement you had
to that to that place no love no
that's just a basketball
basketball giving up basketball was huge
for me i loved playing that game
i started playing basketball when i was
18. that's a little late are you better
offensive defensive what do you like
more do you like to shoot from a
distance do you like i was a runner i i
was very very quick on my feet
and i was a good jumper too
i typically play uh played the uh
the the four position you know what's
that forward oh the forward position
forward position but anyway um so that
that that was the hardest uh uh for me
to give up um but and the the other
thing that i remember i had to do
to hand in my party document to the
party secretary of the university
and uh he made a comment
yeah we probably won't hear much about
you but uh we know that you're going to
do something very important so he
thought ahead and had an inkling that
i'm going i'm gonna go someplace uh
undercover or something like that
and then i packed my bags
and got on a train uh to berlin for
another one of those secret meetings
with uh
my my new handler
nikolai
so and he
came another test that that
would have been quite easy to fail
so i
i had lived uh in vienna for six years
in a dorm even when i became a an
employee of the university they didn't
they didn't have apartments i was still
living in a dorm in any one in a single
room with a bed a chair and a table
and toilet down the down the hallway
so i figured you know berlin kgb i'm
gonna get a nice apartment right
and so uh
nikolai
took me into his car we started talking
a little bit and then he said
i have a task for you already your first
task is to find yourself a place to live
i mean i don't think i showed it in my
face
but you know my heart my my my heart
dropped like down to into my pants i
i knew this wasn't nearly impossible
because there was a severe shortage of
housing in in in everywhere in germany
east germany
and all the apartments and homes were
controlled by
by the government
you you know there were long waiting
lists uh nine i know i knew couples that
were promised maybe to get an apartment
uh
five years down the road
so
then they would postpone their decision
to have a child anyway this wasn't
possible
uh well
you know but this was a test okay
and so again because i had to be
inventive now i had to figure out
how to get out of an impossible
situation i didn't realize it then at
all
i just like went with a flow you know
what do i do
so what i did
i went i took the the train the city
train
to the very last stop
a little uh town called acna
and i wandered around in that town and
knocked on doors and asked people if
they knew
where somebody might have a place to
live
and after a couple of hours somebody
said there's this lady that and she gave
me they gave me the address
and i talked to the lady and she said i
happen to have a place that you might uh
that where you might be able to stay it
was an outbuilding
and
i don't know what it what it served it
was not a garage it was concrete
and it had
a bed
and a chair
a running cold water and a stove a cold
stove that was my was going to be pretty
basic pretty basic that's the faces are
you kidding me
that's the uh toilet across the the yard
of course yeah
well all the essentials what are you
complaining about you were right
you're right you had to run the uh the
special james bond had to run this
special operation out of the yes out
house
to
my credit and i think that that uh that
established part of my reputation i
didn't complain at all to nikolai no
that was part of the test probably yeah
i just told him you know i found
something and so uh for
six months
i would get up in the morning get on the
train
and walk around in the city you know
did some operational stuff and
operational training i went to the
library did a lot of reading in the
library
and then i found the basketball team
that i could join so at least i could
take a shower
twice a week
and
and
apparently
i it took about six months that i was
still on probation
because after six months nikolai one day
we were still meeting in his car
he said he handed me a key he said
i'm going to take you to your new
apartment
now i and i didn't know this you know
that now i was really in
okay
imagine you know the hurdles you have to
jump over and how many times you can
fail but you know but not complaining
not asking questions yes
i mean that was something you've written
about um
i think he wrote that bosses do not like
to hear complaints or problems they
prefer solutions that's right so what
was your interaction like with the
bosses does that
essentially
um represent
the way it went forward as well
no complaints no complaints no arguments
no no
i know this better i was taking it all
in
now the the the technical guys you know
they taught me something i didn't know
that made sense uh
um
what nikolai some of the stuff that he
taught me
was somewhat questionable he was a
generalist
and some things he didn't know really
well so i could have like asked probed a
little bit but i didn't
so i just played along
so this new apartment was uh
it was a studio it had a
kitchen
with running cold water
and the bathroom was just one flight
down the toilet not a bathroom uh one
flight down the
stairs an upgrade it was a big upgrade
and he gave me
uh i think he gave me a thousand mark to
buy buy furniture
and in that place i
actually i also bought a tv and started
watching west german television so
so it
i finally had a
decent place to stay
um
and the the
my training in berlin took about two
years
you